We've now seen a few
improvements to the naive
version of the Ford-Fulkerson method.
But this isn't the end of the story.
There are some even more sophisticated
approaches that improve the run time
even further, also based on
the idea of augmenting flows.
There's also a family of
algorithms called push relabel,
that allow the internal
vertices to absorb flow
during the intermediate
phases of the algorithm.
In practice,
these seem to perform the best.
Beyond just seeing the algorithms in
this lesson, we examined the max-flow,
min-cut theorem.
This was more than just a trick for
proving the correctness
of forward focusing.
It's part of a larger pattern of duality
that provides important insight in
a variety of contexts.
We'll discuss this
more in a later lesson